[Music]
in spy news
what do you spy I submitted by a Julio's
evil cousin doesn't say that what would
your evil cousin's name be like oh yeah
what's her name it really says submitted
by Lou Thesz evil twin I think is in my
mind I just thought like oh she doesn't
have a twin but she does have a cousin
what would that evil cousin look like
and then my mind went home
it's Booya okay account a condominium
board president has been using
surveillance cameras to issue forty
thousand dollars a month in fines and to
residents he's like the high school hall
monitor that found his dream job
forty thousand dollars and fine tile
telling us bid have board presidents for
condominiums yeah this is just like one
person the sometimes it's a whole board
like we have association yeah you guys
have a HOA yeah ah is there HOA meetings
yes we never got along
but there's HOA meetings and then they
voted they just voted in the president
and they nominally they run it like it's
it's crazy I like it and I don't like it
we haven't gotten to a single me I don't
know if we're supposed to or it's
possible I like it cuz it keeps it clean
I mean the streets kind of clean and
organized but I don't like it cuz if
they don't like you they gang up on you
like a [ __ ] game [ __ ] them we don't
do anything for them not to like that
you might just you never know one day
they might not just they just might one
jealous [ __ ] might not like all
the cars on your street one jazz mother
might might might think you know what
[ __ ] Bluff ass bar over there I don't
like his body cuz I'm 60 years old and I
got a body like him so I'ma be a [ __ ]
jealous [ __ ] and start some [ __ ]
that's what happened to us like little
little nitpicky things yeah the pipe are
not ice and that's wrong with their
house like hmm
I don't like it when there's three dogs
that are just being walked and now
there's a two dog policy yep I thought
don't alter the rules just kill our dog
oh yeah easy and we'll just share it
with the [ __ ] HOA before and break
the rule we won't happy dogs huh foster
one of your dogs out to anyone of us no
I'm gonna kill it so that they can get
the [ __ ] video and get traumatized
see what you made me do
oh you're gonna film it - yeah you sixty
year old man like you to say that head
of everyone right now but anyway so
there's this board president his name is
Paul
why is he so bored what can you Paul why
do you have [ __ ] loser this is job
no it's not he's me you thinking about
too far in my view at least he's making
if the money is going back into the
community he's making the community a
lot of money 40 G's in a month
fine let's hear the story before I jump
the gun that's a lot of [ __ ] money
dude forty thousand a month people be
violating Canadian dollars so it's like
31 thousand years that's still a lot of
money per month for HOA I think HOA gets
like a couple thousand or something yeah
and so this president he's just he's not
even fazed by all the hate he's getting
you're just saying like gay well people
need to learn the rules of this building
if they don't like it then too bad
that's what's pretty much you think but
the battle was trying to get killed
yeah the residents they you they were
even protesting I think behind Atta
they're not gonna kill anyone
yeah the residents were protesting
outside of the building just saying like
you know it's not fair
they're just going to crazy like this is
how ridiculous it is so one resident he
received a two hundred dollar fine for
driving away before the parking gate was
completely closed oh I always do that
yeah well I'm supposed to wait until
it's closed so then bums don't walk in
or something yeah another one received a
280 dollar fine for putting up signs to
alert other residents of the enforcement
because this fool is using surveillance
cameras all over the building like there
is even three cameras where the garbage
is so it's like in the garbage area
there's three surveillance cameras
trying to wash his trash another one
received a $200 fine for improper
cardboard disposal and another $200
penalty for a trash related infraction
this was so thorough he's in the wrong
field he should be like house inspector
huh health inspector help yeah things
that are like detrimental like that's
life or death you know like a doctor
yeah dick Hospital or like you know
things that if you're negligent then you
can kill mmm accountant yeah I guess
yeah oh yeah you got to be pretty
perfect that's the nurse yeah yeah but
it's not life or death I was thinking
life or death like oh like where the
military like military stuff you know
stuff like that maybe he you be do he'll
do better there cuz this [ __ ] is like
when people make [ __ ] that's so [ __ ]
important two things that really don't
matter that much like they they kind of
seem crazy how old is he
I'm not sure easy it checked on these
like fake tickets and fake fees that
he's giving out like we can go to a
parking lot and this guy the not this
part like the security guard comes
around he writes out a fake ticket you
don't have to pay for you throw it away
like getting really I never seen a fake
ticket they do that yeah we actually
have that other see the warning yeah
they're warning me but I think it for
the HOA they have actual tickets though
and is legal I think it's legal yeah cuz
HOA there are HOA fines like if you
violate the agreement and like let's say
you don't [ __ ] keep your grass you
know nice and it's devaluing the
property around you then you're you're
causing other people to lose money so
then you get fine the city does that to
you oh yeah yeah if you don't mow your
lawn yep the city's like a giant HOA
tank so show you guys this quick clip
you even get in trouble if you like
paint your house like a ridiculous color
yeah because they're haters bat for HOA
or in the city city really Bismol house
before you put the [ __ ] green frame
absolutely here's a quick clip his dad's
house
these are the residents outside
protesting in front of their own
building and on public with a long list
of what they say are outrageous fines I
got a two hundred dollar fine for
driving away before the gate was fully
closed no she got two hundred dollar
fine for the cardboard and a two hundred
dollar fine for the trash according to
residents more than forty thousand
dollars in fines was issued just last
month an extensive network of
surveillance cameras used to enforce the
rules
is people feeling like they're living in
a prison he is strata president allene
Stannah and he's not at all watching
them the cameras are installed in the
common areas we need to make that
distinction
what is he German or something Oh
thirties early forties seaman Islands
Donna
they can't deep throne the president
he's like a key yeah impeach see the
president of the HOA or Z like oh yeah
then he was voted in right yeah you guys
wanted this [ __ ] so unless there's no
other nominations and that was it I bet
he was just like someone in charge of
the building yeah the building either
that or you know because for my
apartment you know we have we have
people like staff that are in charge of
the building and you know they run all
that stuff but that's weird
that guy sucks yeah do you think you
wouldn't without the future might be his
ass there's Denny so much money on
stupid it depends okay so I I do see the
benefit in stuff like this because I
[ __ ] hate shitty ass neighbors yep
that do some stupid [ __ ] like just the
other week these guys were moving and
then they they [ __ ] up the elevator by
holding it the whole time for like an
hour straight and like Oh dad didn't
care about anybody else using the
elevator they just wanted to like keep
it on their level while they load it up
and do all this stupid [ __ ] and they
broke the elevator yeah so there's a lot
of inconsiderate people and I think they
should be punished but there's also like
that fine line between like all right
you're going too [ __ ] far yeah you
accidentally threw the cardboard in not
the recycling trash and then now you get
fines you like the gate one is
ridiculous that is pretty crazy but I
can feel what Joe's saying cuz when we
lived in our I guess the you would call
an apartment there were people so you
have like your trash chute right all you
have to do is you go into this room with
the trash chute you open up this like
this like gate looking thing and then
you just drop your trash in the chute
done people would just leave their trash
with the bag untied like outside of the
chute I'm like what the [ __ ] is an
expensive ass apartment like how do you
have no [ __ ] class so I can see what
you probably put surveillances in the
trash sure because then the whole that
whole floor just smells like [ __ ]
I would like surveillance in the tracks
room and all that because what if I get
raped or something
thank you safe I feel safer like so in
my trash chute right the trash chute
there's no windows nothing it's just a
[ __ ] room right yeah and then when
you go in there it's a heavy ass door
one time I went in and do his feathers
all over the floor and I was like this
somebody rape a duck in here like what
the [ __ ] a part of me was like dude duck
got [ __ ] in here and the other part
was like why didn't they clean up all
these feathers and put it away
if I saw that camera [ __ ] like I would
look at him be like all right apartment
whatever that's [ __ ] up man that's
inconsiderate you just left your trash
on the floor like that last Lisa yeah I
guess I wouldn't mind that either it was
like secluded areas and I wonder [ __ ]
that happens but a little too far
this is this is kind of excessive I do
agree it's definitely excessive cuz he
lived there too yeah well imagine he
doesn't live there yeah no no it's not
like
in there but I'm assuming some I would
think cuz I'm right now what I've
discussed I was getting death threats
like every single day and he has to face
these people that foo looks like he got
bad social skills and all he cares about
are the rules yeah like all he cares
about is life well you you violated this
and you're just gonna get fined this if
I don't do it next time
yeah probably makes the most sense to
him cuz very black and white yeah it's
just clear maybe his family owns the
building and they're about to go
bankrupt or lose the bill to make money
yeah but that HOA money though he can't
use it for his personal use like it's
supposed to be for the HOA sure it goes
back to the HOA fun or doesn't go to the
building no and then you vote on what
you do with the money yeah
make the place nicer better investments
for the building I saw a little bit of
graffiti on that building that [ __ ]
needs to be cleaned up a little bit
you should get fine I know you're not
doing your job you're not maintaining
this building [ __ ] a couple nights
ago you know in our office the LA office
we have that huge gate right so me and
David just finished dinner we were
driving in and there was this like
homeless dude
he looked like Mexican Jesus like
shoulder-length hair a beard all this
stuff and for some odd reason he was
directing traffic at our gate why so we
pull up and then like he's at our gate
and he's like go in go in and I'm like
what the [ __ ] like who is this guy so I
Drive in and then I turn around and I
just have my lights on him just watching
what he does and and so I see these cars
going out and he's like like telling
them to go out telling the cars to go in
and then he picks up his like shopping
cart which he parked in our parking spot
and he leave and then he leaves yeah
that's so considerate you know what I
think that's not that same guy because
there was his other night when I was
leaving the office and I saw him pull
you know that one sign that says I Drive
that way for the exit or whatever he put
the sign right in the center of the gate
it's dad who did that yeah and I was
like what the [ __ ] so I I didn't know I
didn't know if he worked there or not
because he looked like he knew what he
was doing and he didn't look like a
dude from what I saw maybe we don't even
know homeless dude pretty homeless and
he had a shopping cart with a bunch of
junk any left yeah and then I saw him
walking towards the like where the
highway is and then I was like but at
that point I was already pulling out and
I was leaving but I was just like what
is he doing it was really weird hey guys
thanks for watching that last video make
sure to follow us on instagram @ JK
films to watch more videos right up
there
[Music]